sir all right hot breath averse welcome
back to hot breath the show where you
learn comedy from the pros this is
comedians on skype talking comedy where
you get to ask your favorite questions
to your favorite comedians and today's
guest is one of my absolute favorites
one of the most unique voices in comedy
ladies and gentlemen the one and only
the very awake shane torres everyone
give it up for the yawning shane Torres
this is for everybody but it's special
for you he wouldn't do this we
interrupted his morning coffee to get
him on the show everyone so show some
love for Shane here good questions
I'm in high I'm in high media demand I'm
in high and needly Adam and you've got
all the heat right now shame you've got
all the heat you got all the hot breath
that a that's right yeah we've had a lot
of your friends on here so it's exciting
to get you out here so oh they are my
friends they're my competitors oh is
that is that the mindset is that how
you've been so successful no yeah the
last dance and cuddles it seems like in
listening to interviews of you and all
that it almost seems like you're you
have the opposite approach where you try
to be super nice and a lot of that has
actually garnered success am I correct
in assuming that or is it all a facade I
mean I just think it's good to be nice
you know well you know it's not a it's
not a professional approach to me you
know you know like if people don't like
me and I'm nice to him then go [ __ ]
themselves and I have to be nice to
anybody but like you know like I believe
it's good to be good to people you know
what I mean like I don't like it when
people flex their have status because
typically and I've seen it a bunch of
and
buddy who's flexing when they have
status if I've known them before they
didn't flex like that before they had a
gig or I profile thing you know and it's
and it's a condition of the business I
think but it's and they're not bad they
just flex you know they have a little
more weight to throw around so they get
a little more and that's not like bad
but like no [ __ ] that dude people who
I'm I just it's nice to be it's good to
be nice you know and I know 20 people
who are very successful and like huge
names and they couldn't be more decent
be also like I just think you as anybody
who's flexing can kiss my [ __ ] ass
hey yeah you've been around people like
at the level of like a Will Smith so
you've seen the top of the mountain not
the syrup Mountain but the top of the
mountain like what was it like being
around literally like the 1% if we're
talking about entertainment it doesn't
get much bigger than Will Smith what was
that experience like and did you learn
anything from it like what was that
whole thing um well there's something
for kwibi that's not that out yet and
we'll see how it does the current yeah
the current climate has really affected
it but it was a thing Will Smith
apparently he did this thing that was
very successful on his YouTube page or
he had a bucket list of things he wanted
to try in his life and he was just kind
of documenting them and sharing them and
kind of neat you know and then one of
the things you want to do is stand up he
said he did stand up and he liked it but
never wanted to do it again but he saw
that it was very creative and
interesting work and so he came up with
an idea for a show and and that's what
we all did like all me and a bunch of
other comedians you it's hard to learn a
lot from a man like that in that kind of
environment because he's giving his time
to still many people you have to like
you know you get one-on-one moments with
him and stuff for sure but you can't
monopolize his time it's not fair you
know they're like it's a little rude
not fair everybody else in my opinion so
like maybe that goes to me being too
nice maybe I should have tried to but uh
I don't
yeah you learn a lot just by watching
him like yeah like I was watching him no
I was like this guy's a [ __ ] industry
like it's insane to like watch him and
be like you make everybody a shitload of
money like it was wild
just watch because everybody's around
like he just like you he started this
show and there's you know there's so I
was thinking about like I think there
were 12 comics doing it and then all the
crew and all the staff and all the
catering and on people that are just
doing production and people who are
writing and shoot and it was just like
he just did this he just made this
happen yeah you know like it's [ __ ]
bananas yeah so like that's a man's and
industry so I'm sure to be plenty to
learn from him but he was really nice
and like on the second day of shooting
he walked up to me he was like how you
doing good to see you shame like you
know like you you he seemed um he seemed
present mm-hmm
which is like a really big thing with
celebrities a lot of the time I think
some of the people I have met in that
world are not you know like they're not
giving you their attention but he he was
which I really enjoyed a lot from him
someone bugging super-handsome my great
they still in person like you're like I
don't know if it's Hollywood magic in
person too but son of a [ __ ] son of a
[ __ ] you look he looked for K in person
oh dude we all look for K just how we
look in 4k what go let's go on the the
opposite side of the look spectrum to
Bert Kreischer ah what somebody you've
opened for him several times you've been
on tour with him we had dusty slay on
here sharing
funny stories of being on tour with him
but he was coming from he's sober he was
having to drink coffee to keep up but
you seem to be in the lion's den with
him like out there in the thick of it
but just as as a comedian and all the
comedians that watch this and all the
super comedy nerds that watch this like
could you take us into that world of
going on tour with Bert Kreischer
awesome a some of the details there has
been yeah you know it's very interesting
because the man the penis party we all
party but he also it's work is the most
important thing hmm so that's what takes
priority like he drinks after the show
it's not during them before them you
know like maybe if we have a brunch or
something he might have like a Bloody
Mary like not a Bloody Mary but Lee that
I've never really seen him drink before
shows now that I think about it or if
we're having a nice dinner or something
we might have wine but I don't think I
don't think I've ever seen him drink
before show now that I think about it
may but uh but he he's a pro you know
like it's very interesting because the
way he goes you know I think in some
ways like he sells a shitload of tickets
a shitload of people come out but him
talking to as many people and the first
one is people does not have an ego and
he tries hard to be inclusive hmm well
you know he sells a lot of tickets after
his shows I think by being nice meaning
when he shakes a lot of hands and talks
to people it really goes a long way and
they want to come back you know like
that I think it means a lot to them and
he recognizes that and then and we go to
the bus and we get [ __ ] up we get on
tour bus and have a few cocktails then
before you know what it's 5 a.m. and
then the bus is starting when you're
laying in your bunk and you wake up and
you're just like laughs guess we're on
our way to Wilmington or wherever you
know like and then
what do you do on the bus what like what
like being on tour like in just the dead
time what's happening um you know
they're going a lot to do Bert's a lot
of stuff you know he's like he's always
like he creates a lot of content I will
write or try and like you know work on
my own career during the day when I'm
not working for Bert in the sense that
I'm not you know on stage or like
prepping or anything you know like I'm
having a little bit whatever really but
you know look you you go on the drive
you know sometimes you sit there and
watch TV like it sometimes it's like a
day off but you have a show you know
it's not not you know like you're
depending on how if the drive is three
hours and you leave at 10:00 a.m. like
typically like what someone will have
gotten coffee or have made coffee people
will wake up if you're up you know what
sometimes you sleep super [ __ ] late
and you don't even recognize you know
like they're like oh my god it's 2:30 we
were up till 7 you know that kind of
[ __ ] happens everyone so well we just go
no I'm try not to have give you too many
too many salacious details nothing there
it would you think you wouldn't you
would see it because it's very glitzy
and glamorous and it's it's so fun on
the outside but on at the end of the day
on the bus it's mostly guys talking
about dumb [ __ ] getting a little more
drunk than they should and then going to
bed you know like it's not great you
know this isn't Martin Lee crew you know
like we're not doing you know like it's
not the kind of like it's not really
that house it's a good time of course
but it's not a it's not like a [ __ ]
friend you know like it's not there's
nothing wrong with a house that he keeps
and the way he runs [ __ ] you know yeah
that's interesting
yeah I mean like it's fun and we get
[ __ ] up and we eat a lot of good food
and so it's like it's just kind of like
being on vacation a lot with getting to
do comedy and getting paid like you know
like you eat a lot you drink a lot you
like
we will go like exercise during the day
and stuff you know to try and sweat some
of the [ __ ] out but yeah it's not it's
not like there's no [ __ ] nut store
one that we all made a playlist and we
were just listening like Dion and Jackie
Wilson and stuff and drunk driving
through the night and that was super fun
yeah but yeah that was interesting
talking with you loaded just listen even
[ __ ] old oh you know Bill Bell song
yeah it's that seems to be the key does
it yeah but it was like well during the
day he's like he's a he's a person he's
a businessman and he doesn't drink till
after the show it's like there's a
reason he's successful and it's not
because he's drunk every waking minute
it's because he actually does treat show
business like a business yes no that's
what it is
mm-hmm that's great greg Giraldo once
said in showbiz not show fun and I was
that looks pretty funny but yeah you got
a you know like it we want to have a
career yet to treat it like one so is
there anything is he like yeah I mean
that's what he does is what I'm trying
to do like yeah what when he is he
helpful with like does he give you
advice in terms of business advice or
stand-up advice or like what have you
learned from from like an actual
comedian perspective he will will you
learn by watching you know keeping your
mouth shut look there's a lot to learn
and like I can't really go into specific
lessons but I would say like watching
Bert and watching it this level I think
that they won't end having open for
other people that are at big levels is
that there's a it's not just about the
stage and it's not just about
it's about business it's about there's
so many facets to it's a [ __ ]
business and you you creating your
content and being a great great
entertainer is the most important part
of this business but it is not the only
part like by along [ __ ] like there are a
lot of things you have to work with good
people you have to work with smart
people like I remember people being like
I was talking to somebody somebody's
manager and I was opening for them on
like a special or some and sitting there
and they're like then like his manager
and I were just bullshitting a nice
enough person for a suit and we're
bushing and talking us a stocking they
had a picture of of the comedian up on
like a beer ad or something they weren't
supposed to do that we're gonna have to
you they either have to take that down
and we're gonna be like we're gonna have
to ask for more money there's a [ __ ]
like that you don't think of it that's
nothing I would give a [ __ ] about really
but that's why those people are that
that's how they're supposed to earn
money for you you know like that's to
make sure those things don't get taken
advantage so there's those guys you want
to work with smarter people you want to
work in the right venues you want to get
the right audience you want to make the
best comedy you are capable of making
and then make it better the next time
you want you know like you want to know
how much money you spend you want to
work with openers that suit your style
things like that mean it's [ __ ] it's
not a joke it's it's big business like
so like that's how you learn you don't
learn like you've learned other
particular lessons like maybe do this
joke this way and that's kind of thing
like and you learn like like this bit
should flow into this bit this way and
you know those things already you know I
know some of them already and then you
like think about what you've forgotten
but there's just a million things to
learn in this business nice yeah sorry I
get wound up I had my call you're not no
please is that what you were looking for
you are not getting too wounded up my
man that's the info we're looking for is
that that kind of insight that isn't of
available you know that's what this show
tries to capture are those kind of
behind-the-scenes insights that haven't
really been on record before cuz that
helps create better comedy a better
comedian yeah you need to focus on
getting good yeah hmm focus on getting
it to focus on getting good it's like
I'm still doing that and then you focus
on you know opportunities will present
themselves if you put yourself in the
position to get them then you kill those
and you learn you know don't like I've
done and I'm saying this out of
experience of having gone the wrong way
don't treat every event that you get
into like a party that you need to get
[ __ ] up at you know like like go treat
it like a business like when I went to
did news faces I was shit-faced and it
didn't go well and they were wrong but
they were yeah they were they weren't
wrong to have me I mean they were the
people that were there to like supposed
to be looking at me for talent and stuff
who didn't come after me were wrong but
I sincerely believe that but I also
didn't make it easy on them when I was
shit-faced you know I wasn't so
shit-faced I blew an opportunity I think
nobody was looking though so I got
shit-faced it seemed to have all worked
and then you know and then you find a
good comic those good senior comic that
I'll talk you off the bus yeah well so I
can see using the phrase it all worked
out these days is a pretty relative term
man well you're you're still only really
even all your success you're still only
just still beginning in my opinion in
terms of where you're headed because
what is and there are we're about to get
into people's questions but I think a
big thing I've learned from being a fan
of you and studying you is like being
singular in the sense of being uniquely
you onstage and offstage not trying to
fit a specific mold or trying to appease
to an opportunity but it seems like you
have a natural skill of knowing who
you are having that self-awareness and
just letting that be the magnet where
all your success comes from I really
appreciate that but I think nothing
could be further have no idea who I am
like I literally have woken up me like
who is this I I'll say this and I think
this might help answer your statement is
it like I think my goal has always been
this pretty maybe not always but pretty
early on was to tell jokes that only I
could tell meaning they sounded like my
jokes and I sound like me
and like I'm writing my own way and
there were times where I certainly did
not do that in comedy like like I did
like like very early on I was like like
I was just crying 7 to be overly
influenced by comedians I was watching
you know like and like I remember I
think my second set ever I acted like I
thought a comedian should act and that's
like a gross thing because comedians
don't have to act any certain way you
know they still have to be funny I think
when people will say they're not acting
like a comedian it can be also be very
bad because I think that means they
don't have to try and they just they
think that means they don't have to try
and they guides it in [ __ ] acts like
it's not good but you're like they can
do it you don't get it kind of thing
like if it's too abstract
and nothing is actually too abstract
it's just not executed well I think
which is what I mean so like I think be
yourself you know like nobody wants to
see an imitation of Seinfeld and I don't
want to see an imitation of Bert you
know like and like like you just want I
want it to be interesting so I like
seeing interesting people do new things
I haven't seen or I like seeing people
who have done great stuff make more
great stuff
perfect nobody like nobody wants to see
[ __ ] shane battier like you know set
a pic that's not why you go to the
Madison Square Garden you go because you
want to see celebrant throw a dunk down
like they're both important things but
you get it yeah that's a great analogy
to yeah yeah
so let's yeah let's get into a fan
questions here and this first one let's
do uh let's get chase in here first cuz
he's actually watching from work right
now he's such a big fan he's watching
this from work so let's let's get his
question he's a boy open yeah I think he
works at like um I think like a car shop
like a mechanic so I guess there's been
working on cars cause he'll tune in from
work so this one from Chase Bannen well
we'll be sure he puts those [ __ ]
break Edvin yeah that's a great
he's probably huddled in the bathroom
just waiting on his question to get
answered yeah what's your what's your
question chase says first off I saw you
at club 337 and Lafayette and it has
been the funniest comedy show I've ever
seen so far when you say you laugh like
a bully's friend or your laugh is
haunting is there say what did I cut out
where did he see me at club 337 and
Lafayette it's good spot oh right yeah I
love that place Lenard room yeah oh yeah
JP pub man you're a lot - yeah yeah I've
done his beer garden show I haven't done
yeah what was the question 337 yeah yeah
awesome yeah yeah so yeah he's the best
I love him
we have let me say oh here it is okay
when you when you say you laugh like a
bully's friend or your laugh is haunting
is that written into your sets or is a
spontaneous thing you'll do to maintain
momentum
um I have done that with that line I
don't know like you I've used that line
to build momentum omentum in an act like
when somebody has a particular laughs
you'd say something like that but it's
really just about it being present
you're like you yourself being present
like when you hear somebody with a
particular lap or a waitress crowd some
power drinks or you know whatever
somebody's chair slides do it so if you
acknowledge it you have to be present
like that's it like if you are not
present doing comedy than it is not your
best stuff ever hmm
you know like and like that is something
you know I can't say I've done it every
night but I try hard like you everybody
paid to get a sitter
you know and or do whatever and when
comedy clubs come back soon hopefully
people are gonna be going through even
more trouble and have more on their
minds you need to give them something
great they're still spending their
[ __ ] you know what I mean like it's
it that's why you're there so they don't
like you're there like rates online
money for yourself number one but you
know other people are paying for their
experience watching you yeah it'll be in
my mom um they have yeah I wouldn't say
that I don't think they're written
really as much as they are just like a
little trick I have that I use which
even I even and even that I don't know
is something that I want to be doing
anymore because the if it's a trick then
it kind of can become a habit and then
it can become a bad habit so like I may
like move away from that not not being
present necessarily but like using lines
that are essentially not as spontaneous
as they look
all right well good good yes which I
which I think is bad actually
yeah yeah sorry I tried to be candid and
pulled the curtain back too much Jeff
no that's good to know because he's a
comedian check under the hood for me
haha alright next one coming from
Christopher Christopher CJ James will
Shane Torres vote Guy Fieri for
president what will you vote Guy Fieri
for president that's what now question
was man look come on
what a dick policies I guess probably
not know I either I'm sure he's a
sweetie he's a sweet enough dude but
yeah nah I don't know be if I want him
politicking we already have one
television personality in the White
House and the [ __ ] [ __ ] us over
pretty good
are you are you tired of that yeah joke
like are you tired of having like
talking about that joke no okay I don't
care I don't care I I get it so it's a
thing I got known for but it's like I'm
very well determined to not be a one-hit
wonder you know like like that's not
that's not a thing I want and I guess
that makes sense
you know like I'm clearly that makes
this was like I don't think I am I think
that's just the thing like that is the
thing that went by roll and people who
are I've only watched that will know me
from which is fine you know like but I
have jokes that are better than that
joke that just
means to be at the moment it's a great
bit they're proud of it but it just
happens to be hit at the right time not
just happen to but hit at the right time
it was a good take and I'm very proud of
it and I think the joke makes sense and
I think it's a valuable lesson in the
joke but I do think I've written jokes
that are funnier and I think if people
look at my my body of work and when my
next special comes out whenever that is
but don't see that too so yeah where did
it start because like I mean the coding
clip is like a four-minute bit but like
what was the first line of that entire
bit that really like sparked that oh I'm
on to something here
oh I hated no I thought it was hacky
that people used him as a reference all
the time okay I thought it was the
airport like when I would go to comedy
and people were just like oh you know
like guys here it's like [ __ ] you dude
like I just you want to [ __ ] on this
dude for the exact same thing the irony
of it is they didn't get that's exactly
what they were doing here's the thing
they were making fun of him for for
creating bad for lack of a better word
contents you know and I was they and
they know is to say yeah and then I
thought to myself it's like I knew they
weren't bad people they were making
these jokes but I was just like I'm not
talking about the the line was just like
well what did he ever do that was that
bad mm-hmm you know like and then and
then like then the line that followed
was that's where the joke writing came
in and it started there was like you
know like because as far as I can tell
all he ever did was follow his dreams
and that and then and then that's where
I really started doing heavy lifting on
the joke after that so it is that heavy
lifting like pinned to paper like well
who else do we treat like this and then
Nickelback comes up like what is that
heavy lifting
um there's a little bit I mean that goes
ten to the way I think I think or other
anyone would think like I made like the
heavy-lifting comes in so that's a
premise and that's one line of a joke
that part of that Fieri admit and so the
rest of it is like how do I want to be
creative in this bit and how does what
direction do I want to take this in like
you know like do I want to make it
hypothetical do I actually want to
research you know like there's a million
ways to go about it and that's where
like becoming a comedian and and
peppering your dish of comedy for people
comes in like that's not you know like
if I could have left it there you know
and it could have just been a 10-second
joke
I could look to dot dot and wash my
hands of it that would have been enough
for me that's a clever joke he could
probably could have done more with that
is what people would have said but I
think I got a lot out of it you know
like and I started thinking about what
is next
like what else is in that world what
make sense you know like it's just all
you could kind of reverse-engineer
sometimes and you like like well this is
kind of like sometimes you get so close
to a bit in a joke to make you making
such a good point that just the way you
feel about something can support the
joke by like saying it yeah like and I
don't know exactly how to explain it but
I know I've seen it done if you showed
me someone's a bit I could like what's
next to something in what after
subjecting your palm to do
[Music]
okay so I'll reference myself so on my
album I do a bit about weddings and
about people and uh and the bit after it
is a bit about babies falling out of
windows but weddings and babies go
together
kind of like they're just they live next
to one another in a neighborhood of
subject matter and there's no transition
but like that's a feel when I did that
and I did the jokes like that live and I
would do them like that and they're that
way on them if that one Falls the other
it's not hard for me to see for anyone
to see how I got to that from wedding
nights to baby it wasn't like wedding
nights and then like Tiger Kingdom you
know like I do or whatever of course
you're like they you know like you like
yeah so that can be an element in the
jail and even you're like it seems how
you say things as well because you did
study like vocal performance in college
and it seems like you are intentional
about saying things louder sometimes or
saying them quieter and like the
intonation you have it seems like you
take it down to that fine of an approach
or am I just over analyzing yeah no no I
I used tone Oh in volume a stone in
volume for sure you know but everyone
does maybe I am a little too inflicted
with how I use it but I know like
Hedberg each town mm-hmm like more maybe
better than most you know like Louis
black uses tone and volume you know like
Michael changes tone it's just different
like I mean maybe my range changes a
little more than a lot of people but um
yeah everyone uses tone and like it but
it's like it that is a tool to keep an
audience you know it's a tool it's it's
it's a there's a variety of ways to use
it it's uh but that is a way on audience
states president when the shift when
your tone shifts it's a way for you to
inflect jokes it's a way for you to like
calm an audience down there's a what
there's there's a lot of weapons with
tone there's a lot of ways to use it as
a weapon so to calm an audience down you
almost bring your
voice down so then they have to listen
harder and then go higher when you
really want to like emphasize something
is that kind of you can't yeah I mean
kinda that's it but like you can also
use it to build like I I have a six
minute joke about everything bagels and
the tone is pretty much the same the
whole time but it it builds the longer
it goes I mean the weapon in that joke
isn't necessarily the way there's like
massive blister and punchlines in it but
there are these ways that it kind of
builds even though it stays the same
place because they like there's a way to
hold people in their pot it's like like
someone carrying an egg on the back of
their hand or something you know like
you can that is a way to like build
tension it's just to like walk around
like you know look like hold it is he
gonna be able to keep it is it what's
coming at house is gonna change like you
like you know like that so that's a way
to do it and when it comes to the
physicality side it seems your intention
about like having your like hand on your
hip and you will kind of like emphasize
different like I'm guessing that's
intentional because I've seen on your
conan and also your other sets so it's
like what what's going on here yes it
just was like OCD and then just the
habit I have I don't know man I kid it
is what it is now oh is it it might be a
little too late to change it I wish I
could and people people might like it
like well he's not so weird after all
but uh we'll see if that changes oh okay
so that's just something as a comedian
you're constantly evolving and that's
just kind of idea going to iron out I
guess or I would just say it's just a
thing I do okay you know some people
jiggle their keys in their pocket you
know some people like chew on too
like it's just a habit I have a tick you
know some people favor their to look to
their left and to the right on stage
some people just are that way you know
cool
some people strut some people pause just
just everything I do I guess
cool yeah you see I go like deep I like
see something I'm like put why so I'm
that's why I kind of nerd out on that
stuff ya know yeah but I wasn't
overthinking the voice stuff so we're on
the right track with that
so yeah yeah you're you're you don't
want to you're bad 150 all right so yeah
let's let's uh let's run through these
questions here sorry kids I um I got a
little carried away cuz then what just
being a fan and just seeing how unique
you are onstage I always love to know
the process behind that this one comes
from Aaron deceiver he asks do you have
it oh [ __ ]
calm down alright so the next question
here but Aaron deceiver he says do you
have a dream project you would like to
do a sitcom or otherwise
[Music]
yeah it's more yeah more I'm working on
something a couple of things some of
them are not dream projects some of them
are just things I'm excited about and
then some are like big ones but I'm
holding those close to this right now
but I do happen but I don't know like I
have them because like uh you know the
training project is to have a nice life
through comedy and perform the way I
want to get the things I want out of it
and that comes with assembling other
building blocks and making good things
cool very diplomatic answer there so
let's thank you it was it was
informative but still it was like an egg
on the back of your hand we're still
like oh there's something happening
there he's not yet but yeah that's still
good yeah that's that's good to know
though the next I am yeah I I'll tell
you this there's a delay yes a delay so
anytime I make a joke it takes so long
for you to laugh and I'm like oh my god
like I'm just dying and bombing here so
they rode the way on the Skype so it's
like you're just like and I just like
yeah like I just I want to make
beautiful stuff I think you're just like
yeah I've noticed the delay as well I've
noticed that as well yeah yeah because
like I'll say something yeah and then
I'll start talking through what you're
saying probably as we go back and forth
now but I'm onna I'm using my phone as a
hotspot because my internet has been
glitchy today and I didn't want to risk
it
so we have the glitch anyway which is
perfect but you're in Atlanta right yes
yeah our unit Lena yeah
okay okay oh so yeah another question
yeah we gotta - this was Justin Williams
and then John yes all right so Justin
Williams asked what's your favorite
place to perform clubs I mean I mean you
get that question a lot so the clubs
it's like on the road it's comedy on
state helium Portland my home club in
New York it's the Comedy Cellar there is
no greater place cities like Chicago
zany's is great they're the people who
are very good to me there and I love
Chicago as a city Boston is great
I like cities you know so it's a shows
they may not know about I mean you know
about star born in land that's one of my
favorite places ever to play the mid Sam
bones room the Dragons Den in New
Orleans is great and you know there's
kind of independent shows that are
awesome but JJ's in Chattanooga is it's
wild it's super fun I've done yeah so
you know there's a ton of them really
but they're all deer like yeah yeah I
mean this or New York is no mecca level
stuff yeah I saw a photo with you on
stage with this oh yeah oh and will ya
and sylvans there's the other person
yeah the three of it yeah Dave brought
me on stage was pretty cool that's a big
moment yeah yeah no big deal yeah yeah
this is a big that's a very cool moment
Jon Barwick asks was he a manager at
Arby's
knows a it was a couple of different
local burger a local burger chain in
Texas and then a TGI Fridays but Arby's
is funnier as a word so I used our piece
pulling back the curtain here yeah also
and oh and chase says he likes how
patton oswalt uses tone and volume as
well cool
it's brilliant yeah have you worked with
hands great new special out today I
think yeah we worked here a few times
he's been nice enough to have me on
stuff he did I opened for him on the
special before the this past one this
one that comes out today opened on that
special he one of my big crowning
moments today eight in comedy is he did
a podcast and on the podcast they asked
if he could steal someone's joke whose
would it be and he said Gary Goldman's
state capitals joke and mine so you know
and I'm like I love and he is a he's
like a guy for me like in comedy that is
like very important so that was very
flattering yeah the the Guy Fieri joke
right you're saying yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was that the there wasn't the
ex-girlfriend shampoo bottle do so well
yeah i those like it's a it was a it was
huge when it happened and even now with
all this going on when you think i need
to think of some good things that might
be a thing i think of on occasion so
like you've had we talked about you
getting asked to come on stage with Dave
Attell and like Patton Oswalt saying
things like that I mean are there any
others of those moments they come to
mind that it's just like is this la is
this real life type of deal
it's always flattering man because those
people are great you know I mean looking
they they I mean they're brilliant uh uh
a Gaffigan walked up to me once at a
show it was like he talked to me about
the bit that's flattering spending time
with people when they treat you as
appeared no matter who they are then
it's like it had real success that's
cool
it feels good because it feels like
you're capable you know like they don't
they're not just giving it out and
they're not and I got good I know I'm
good but it's it's nice to see from
people who had success and this could
tie in to our final question actually of
who is your biggest influence from the
past and who is another young comic you
think people should pay attention to
hmmm I think Sam Evans is a comedian
people should be watching okay all the
time brilliant he's a good friend but
he's got an album coming out next week
called sweet baby boy people should
check it out and influence it's there
like all my influences have been
cancelled due to their bad condo so like
I loved Louie and I love coffee it like
you know like you love people you know
it so it's just and then it's like but I
mean they were big for me but somebody
and they gets a weird question to ask I
think because it makes you like
whimsical and you think about people
that did that for you in the night oh
yeah they turn up to be [ __ ] scumbags
I tell was a person I love this comedy I
love watching
I love Kathleen Madigan I think she's
great
I think somebody who really did it
instead of it and then like I mean I
guess they're kind of peers of mine but
Jackie Kashian
and Lori killed Martin are both amazing
I would say peers on the sense of like
we kind of we work in the same places
and stuff but I think they're just so
special like and I remember watching
Jackie years and years ago before I even
heard of Laurie you know it's just like
this woman it's blistering like it's
just brilliant
alright well this this has been a this
has been great Shane thank you so much
for taking the time to do this
all right there yeah this was very nice
is there any closing advice or wisdom
you could bestow upon us
comedians before we add apart here or
anything you've learned how in comedy
shame
quo years 12 years something is there
anything cuz it's even more just like
things you've learned along the way like
is there anything you've learned that
you could like share with us to kind of
help the next generation of comedians I
think work hard be smart and be nice
pretty simple things you know I think
I'm pretty easy to do and they go a long
way and yeah I think yeah like work do
it take it seriously if you want to be
career and treat it like a career um all
right there you have it hot breath
diverse Shane torres ladies and
gentleman come out of applause can i
plug something let him know I was just
about to say where yeah let them know
everything and how they can support you
you need to watch good god tonight on
Twitch at 6 o'clock Pacific nine o'clock
Eastern okay hold it's my show I do with
a few other comedians
we've very good lineup tonight it's on
hold on the hold the phone channel on
twitch okay to livestream comedy show
Tim McLaughlin Michael Fox tons of great
people Tom's a car from Conan Phoebe
bottoms Caitlyn from and bro French
festival lots of great stuff you did
come buddy fun so tune in I want people
to watch it god damn it
alright anywhere else you want them to
go and just to support shane torres
people not keep an eye out for [ __ ] when
you know when this all blows over I'll
be back and I can't wait to see you guys
out there shows awesome
all right well Shane Torres spinner
breath no man